Okay.
So here to fore in this course we have treated government as one of two things,
either as in Desoto,
his frame of reference,
a guarantor property rights,
uh,
or as just background background material as with Smith,
where the grab oven of wealth of nations and the invisible hand story is to
encourage governments to allow free markets and free trade.
But there's not much talk about governments and how they behave.
And today I wanted to correct that deficiency of level by talking about
government and in particular about the government in the United States.
Uh,
and then turning to the Vioxx,
the Merck Vioxx case,
uh,
and looking at a little bit of video of Mark Lanier who is the main trial lawyer
litigant,
uh,
nationally in uh,
the MERC matter.
Now,
uh,
United States is a very unusual political system.
It is a so called presidential system,
often copied.
There are probably,
I haven't counted them.
There are probably 20,
perhaps 25 countries with regimes that look on the surface,
like the American one.
And they have in common that almost every one of them has failed.
Almost every one of them.
He is wildly unstable.
And the organic growth of the very complex American constitutional order is,
uh,
is essentially unique.
And it begins with a,
what I think of as the genius of the founding fathers.
They expressed particularly in federalist 10,
federalist 51 where the object is to create a complex system and a system which
makes it hard for people to put together winning coalitions in favor of new
policies,
which gives enormous advantage to those defending existing policies and which by
the scale and complexity of so largest system.
And they thought when they began of the 13 colonies as a huge republic and,
and it was a huge republic.
And what came after is,
is the largest complex republic.
Uh,
the world has known and probably,
uh,
it is as large as is feasible,
with a Republican form of government.
The combination of federalism.
So there are two major layers of government and the expected diversity of so
larger,
larger country make it hard to form majority coalitions.
And even when you formed majority coalitions,
the system of checks and balances in the constitution augmented by the leader,
he merchants of the committee system in the House and Senate at the federal
level,
uh,
make putting together a winning majority,
very difficult.
Arguably the last presidential and congressional elections created a winning
coalition for some form of health care reform.
The one would have to admit that listening to the election there,
it wasn't much specificity about what that might be.
And if you watch what's happened since the powerful resistance to change,
which is built into the system,
has manifested itself.
Now from the point of view of capitalism,
it is generally suppose that this is a plus.
That the stability of economic policy and the endurance of,
of laws relating to property patents,
uh,
commerce,
that the relative stability of all that owes something to the fact that no mere
shortlived majority can transform the American political system and its
policies.
And I think that's broadly true.
The only contingency in which one would fear for the American republic.
And there are people,
uh,
New York Times column is Frank Rich,
for example.
Uh,
uh,
New York Times columnist David Brooks for another example.
Uh,
who fear that we've come to that to that difficult position.
And that position is this.
If the existing status quo is unsustainable,
as one might have thought the status quo on the regulation of banking and
mortgages was a six months or a year ago.
And as some argue the healthcare system is now,
then all the checks and balances which make change difficult may make,
may make it impossible to escape from that very difficult status quo.
Now,
I am a,
uh,
personally an optimist about the ingenuity and resilience of American,
the American political and economic order.
But it's important right now to begin what we're doing today.
Understanding that changing public policy is,
uh,
a heroic undertaking.
The change of public policy,
which will be in the background in the Vioxx case is tort reform and a part and
which,
uh,
plays a huge role in the Vioxx case.
Tort Law does a,
and is in the background as a major factor in the health care reform story
because the risk to medical practitioners from surgeons to nurses,
uh,
that is presented by tort law is very great and we'll try to cover some of that.
Uh,
using Vioxx as our case.
When Vioxx was in the testing stage,
I went to my internist and tried to talk him into getting me into the trial
because I was still playing tennis then.
And violence allowed me to box blacks seemed like a miracle drug.
And,
uh,
the merit of it,
a Cox two inhibitor was that it seemed to reduce inflammation in your joints and
therefore reduce pain without creating inflammation,
any erosion in the intestine,
a aspirin and other similar drugs,
uh,
reduce inflammation in the joints,
but as a byproduct,
a tear at the,
at the intestine.
And,
uh,
he was wise enough to say,
you know,
not every,
not every innovation is what it appears to be.
And I would urge you not to be in the trials and being a compliant fellow.
I took his advice and I in retrospect,
I guess I'm glad
the American system,
and this is not part of the original design has built up and the enormous
practice in lobbying and high powered lawyering at the federal level a and k
street is to,
is to lobbying what Wall Street is to finance.
And the existence of trade associations for every imaginable thing is a leading
factor in American politics.
And whomsoever would seek to control or create some new efficiency or new new
form of justice in public policy has to fight her or his way through k street.
The,
and I'm about to give you,
uh,
a series of generalizations which are broadly true,
each admits of exceptions,
but they are about what are the advantages if we want to play the K street game.
One is concentrated interest where a particular class of individuals or
companies have a lot at stake is a huge advantage.
And why is it a huge advantage?
Because it will provoke them to spend money on lobbying and influence.
And they will have the money.
Whereas dispersed interests where there are perhaps tens of thousands or even
millions of people who have some small stake in and outcome,
uh,
will not readily form a well financed,
interest association and will therefore be less strong than a concentrated a set
of interests which form a well financed,
uh,
coalition.
Uh,
it goes with the second point is a truism,
a well financed causes Trump world financed ones and there are exceptions to
that but not a lot and remember that it is,
it is a market society and money talks.
It is a market society in which the First Amendment gives money rights.
That is if I want to spend money putting,
putting forth a point of view and you want to regulate my right to do that,
uh,
my first recourse of defense for the right will be to go to the courts and say
that you're infringing my right of self expression.
And the courts have often not unambiguously but often a ruled in favor of that
view.
Defending the status quo is a hell of a lot easier than changing it.
The legislative process is full of veto points.
The commonest result for legislation introduced in the House of Representatives
is that it is assigned to a committee and nothing else happens.
It's assigned to a committee and nobody brings it to the floor for a vote.
The committee may not even hold hearings if the chair of the committee is
hostile to it,
he prob hostile to it.
Any thinks it might have support,
he will refuse to hold hearings and the and in a way that is not really the
subject to this course.
The succession of ways in which you can kill new legislation is a spectacular.
Another issue,
the one up the one about agency agency capture is a big advantage and by this we
mean that if you are in the airline business let us say and there is a civil
aeronautics bureau which is assigned the task of regulating your industry.
If your industry can make an alliance with that agency itself can capture the
agency,
that can be worth an enormous economic psalm because it will allow you to
structure public policy in a way which suits the combined interests of your
industry.
And something of the same is said to be at play and almost certainly is at play
in the relationship between the pharmaceutical interest and the FDA.
I've just said that and that in at the same time
the ca be shipped similar knowledge bureau,
uh,
rule the airline industry from its inception until the late seventies.
And in the late seventies,
it was repeal the regime.
It created assigned routes to particular companies.
So you would apply to the government for the right to fly from Laguardia in
Chicago,
two Midwest Laguardia,
in New York to Midway in Chicago or from Midway in Chicago to lax.
And the agency you would assign route to make sure that there was not undo price
competition.
Okay.
It would protect oligarchical pricing
and that is to say highly profitable pricing.
It would work the Porter's five forces,
if you will,
to the advantage of the incumbent airlines.
A new entrance could be frozen out.
A price competition was minimal.
Most of the competition had to do with amenities.
Most famously with mmm
airline attendants averaging 25 years of age and all women and none married.
Um,
the,
um,
air travel business was restricted and wildly inefficient.
And what killed this arrangement was the observation made by some law and
economics people
that the airlines,
which were not subject to it,
and the only airlines that weren't subject to this regulation were ones which
flew entirely in one state.
And the most famous case was the flight between the San Francisco Oakland area
and the Lva,
San Diego area.
We're fares were low.
They were less than half comparable fares on interstate flight.
Uh,
a similar story in,
in Texas from Love Field Dallas in a hub pattern around the state of Texas,
fairs were lower.
Safety was just as good.
Service wasn't quite as good,
but there was genuine price competition.
And this group came to the fore and created a national coalition to deregulate
the airlines.
And the effect,
uh,
was,
well,
let's take somebody at random
who's had,
how am I,
how many of you look forward to air travel?
Does somebody want to give us a 32nd essay on why it's hard to watch.
Not a lot of fun to travel by Air Jay,
I'll save us time.
Uh,
it's because flights are by and large full and the transportation safety
administration provides an initial indignity on each trip.
Um,
and because service is totally minimal,
right?
You have to buy your own Graham crackers for lunch.
The,
the,
uh,
it's,
it's not a,
uh,
unless you five first class or business class,
which Yale does not allow except for the very highest ranking officers,
the university right now.
Um,
uh,
and then he owed early on very long flight.
Uh,
air travel isn't fun at all.
but what it is,
is efficient and it is in real terms,
vastly cheaper than it was under the regulatory regime.
And I bring it up just to point out the advantage of regulation under the old ca
be regime from the point of view of the airlines and not from the point of view
of the passengers.
The effect of deregulation was a long series of bankrupt cheese in which the
legacy carriers,
uh,
went broke.
And those were chimps survived.
They had gotten so fat under the old regime that they were wildly inefficient
and most of them died off and those which survived had to go through convulsive
change to get their operating costs low enough to compete with the new wave
carriers such as southwest or jet blue.
Well,
the FDA is
from a strategic of view,
broadly analogous to the CIB.
The FDA is a huge regulatory juggle,
which creates a powerful obstacles to new entrance and which requires drug
companies to be extremely well financed in order to get new products,
uh,
through the mill.
And the,
the,
the impact of that has been to create a relatively small number of gigantic
pharmaceutical companies,
uh,
many of them very well run,
and to,
and to induce those pharmaceutical companies to aim at blockbuster drugs.
Okay.
A Merck is one of those companies.
It's,
I've showed you this diagram about combining know how with capital and
motivation to get something done and in a highly regulated environment,
you've also got to worry about,
uh,
the regulatory and legal apparatus in a big way.
And these companies are really good at that.
They have adapted to the regime of the food and Drug Administration and are a
terrifically good at that.
And they are able to,
uh,
put up pretty high barriers to competition from new entrants.
And the typical outcome for somebody for a small firm,
which has a drug candidate is that they get to a certain stage in the
preliminary phases of testing and then sell or license the drug to one of the
major pharmaceuticals.
MMM.
Post this slide.
It's the,
it's the history of Merck's Merck's interaction with government and governments
road toward the FDA.
The interesting thing it's in the case about Merck is that its property was
seized during World War One.
And for the American government to seize the property of a corporation is a very
rare event.
But the problem was of course,
World War One,
the Germans were the bad guys.
They ended up having to buy their property back on loans from Wall Street.
And the reason they got the loans is that Merck was a great company,
a great company with centuries of history,
um,
uh,
to legislative acts,
which are perhaps important to the background of this case or the prescription
drug user fee act and of 92 and the FDA modernization of 97,
both of which gave put the drug companies in the position of funding the FDA's
investigation of their proposals.
Now,
in looking for a blockbuster drug,
uh,
think of the Green Square as a space representing all the possible diseases the
drugs can fix.
And they range on the vertical scale from acute at the bottom to chronic on the
top from rare on the bottom to common on the right.
I said chronic up here or I meant chronic up here.
And is it obvious to you where the money is to be made in the pharmaceuticals
business?
Yes.
Back Left,
pardon?
Common and common and chronic.
Because if acute,
the customer may not stay alive long enough to be truly profitable and common
is,
uh,
has its obvious benefit.
So the idea of a Cox two inhibitor,
the business plan behind the Cox two inhibitor was to advertise the hell out of
it and to capture a huge,
a generation of,
uh,
people 40 and older,
with bad knees,
tennis elbow,
all those stiff necks,
all those things which go on for decades.
Uh,
and during the 17 year patent to make billions upon billions of dollars and
blockbuster drugs in fact do make billions upon billions of dollars.
And there is a market failure problem with this model,
which has to do with less common,
with less common and more acute diseases and many,
many small small disease populations get disproportionately small investment in
drug research because of the logic of blockbuster drugs.
Uh,
Merck,
Hans had two really famous CEOs in recent times.
This is Roy van.
I've had both these guys in my classroom to teach this case at one time or
another.
Uh,
Roy Vagelos was a,
uh,
it is an MD and a brilliant MD at a,
at an idealist.
He,
at one point,
I don't know if this is the river blindness drug in this case.
Yeah.
The river behind this drug is one where he,
the government wouldn't pay to affect pay to distribute the drug,
uh,
in Africa,
but he just had merch pay and thinks he got his money back in the motivation of
his research staff and Ray Gil Martin who succeeded him and comes in for great
abuse.
In the mark linear video,
we'll look at,
uh,
Ray Gil Martin is an Mba,
where she had a Harvard Mba and was a hell for leather marketer and he looked at
the Cox two inhibitor market as the best single market,
uh,
available in the generation to mark and put a huge sales force out there and
went a full stop and sometimes a little over the line with the ethics of
inducing doctors to prescribe the drug,
uh,
sometimes by a straight forward favor gaven given sometimes by,
invitation to so called research conferences,
which were in actual fact a golfing holidays of the kind.
Now what's wrong with the Golfing holiday aimed at mds?
If we remember Sharon Oster,
do we remember?
Yes.
Yes we can we scroll on mic.
I remember correctly you said was that if the doctor was willing to go on a
golfing holiday,
that means the opportunity costs is losing,
is not that high.
So it's probably not a doctor that sees a lot.
Okay.
So the doctors were the lowest opportunity costs.
We're going to a why you go to a y and they're not the people you're trying to
reach.
And that's certainly true of,
of the heart technology.
Maybe a little less true of Vioxx where a very low key practice where you're
just just casually advise people to take this drug would be very valuable.
The common law tradition,
um,
the English common law,
uh,
is derived not from legislation but from cases and builds up through precedent
where each new case is analyzed by its analogy or lack thereof,
a to earlier cases which raised the same legal issues.
And
this tradition goes back a thousand years or nearly a thousand years.
And,
uh,
came to the United States with the immigrants who came to New England in the
17th century and is,
uh,
a dominant part of the American legal code,
which is largely separable from Congress.
And the legislative process and central to it is the idea that courts should
make the victims of a careless,
reckless or fraudulent products a whole should make that should bring them back
to a situation as good as they would have been been in if they had not received
the bad product and beyond that often punitive damages where if we say this
person was harmed or the extent of $100,000 so we pay him $100,000 at the
expense of the company,
but we then say this is a huge company.
$100,000 means nothing to this company.
So let's say a hundred minutes
and most of the hundred million is punitive damage,
which nonetheless goes to the victim but is meant to teach the company Elastin.
Well,
from the point of view of business,
punitive damages are very scary and the American legal landscape is a
particularly complex one for that reason because with federalism again versus
rich,
you remember it again versus rich is about tort law and about setting incentives
in a way that works well for society as a whole.
And the problem with Merck Vioxx is similarly that I'll give you one more,
um,
one more,
uh,
common law case to get the feel of this.
Uh,
at the close of World War II,
the guy who owned this property near an airport suit the airport for the noise
of planes going through his airspace.
He said,
I own the airspace.
They can only come through if they have my permission or pay me rent on the use
of my airspace.
And uh,
the plaintiff had a very strong common law precedent.
The common law theory of airspace was that you make a projection from the after
people were sure the world was round.
It's a s it's a spherical projection,
uh,
to the ends of the ends of the universe.
You own everything that is in that spiritual projection over your land.
Now
you were,
you're a judge.
It's 1947.
The airline industry is just getting strong
and you're presented with this case tall.
How would you decide it?
Can we do
thanks Nancy C as the airline industry
is just,
it's just getting a strong,
I might want to incentivize them to keep flying it and keep asking if she would
obviously be very difficult if I let every single person,
it would obviously be very difficult to let the airline industry form if I let
every single person who owns a property control the airspace over their property
because then they'd have to trim the transaction costs would be huge to
negotiate with each and every single person.
Absolutely.
That's,
that nails the question.
So a flight,
a little flight from Chicago to Milwaukee or for Milwaukee to Madison,
Wisconsin or for Madison,
Wisconsin and Minneapolis would involve thousands of transactions and license
fees with the owners of all the land you're going to traverse.
And the airline industry would be stillborn for that reason.
So in the background of this case,
just as in the background of Gan versus rich is creating incentives for those
who are prepared to invest in the generation of value and ultimately of wealth
for the society as a whole.
And,
and,
uh,
Mr. Justice Douglas in May of 1946 wrote the opinion in us versus Cosby,
which,
uh,
decided the case,
in favor of the airlines and against the land owners.
Now the plaintiffs bar,
okay.
Yeah.
Let's not do the summary settling.
Let's see what you remember how we're going to do this DVD stage
play.
This is a set of interviews we sent.
It
ultimately has to settle.
This is one your maybe not all of the cases,
but Merck certainly needs to settle the good cases.
Uh,
what,
what Merton needs to do is wait until the statute of limitations runs.
What that means is that there's a time period after your damaged where you have
to file your lawsuit.
And if you don't file within that time period,
your,
your rights are gone.
Martin needs to go ahead and wait and let that time period run so that,
that there is a fixed a denominator.
How many cases are out there?
And then the numerator,
how many of those is Mark gonna settle can be determined and I'm not sure that
mark needs to settle every case out there.
Uh,
these cases are expensive to fight and they're hard to fight.
And so,
so Merck can satisfactorily settle the difficult,
uh,
cases of serious injury where really I think all of us ultimately agree merch
owes the money.
And then Merck can take those cases of lesser liability and ultimately tell the
lawyers,
you want us to come get us?
And that's where this has got to end up,
I think.
I think there probably about 25 to 30,000 cases that ultimately will be filed
against Merck.
Out of those 25 to 30,000,
how many of them are good cases?
I would guess probably s you've got different degradations of good.
It's like students,
you know,
there's a good and there's be good,
then they're seeing not so good.
And then there's DNF really not good at all.
Um,
uh,
how many a B cases in that grouping?
Uh,
over half of them I think are probably a B cases.
How many of those are sees man?
Maybe a third.
How many of them are D and f?
Eh,
maybe about 25%.
I don't know.
And I'm,
I'm percentages may not add up.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's something in those ranges.
At least
my guest is 12 to $15 billion for liability for Merck.
Um,
I think if Ken Frazier,
the general counsel for Merck came to me and said,
linear,
here's 12 and a half billion dollars,
make my headache go away.
I can come pretty close to two resolving all of his issues.
There's a great deal of difficulty,
uh,
in,
in trying to set up a jurisdiction for hearing these cases.
Uh,
the way the law is set up philosophically,
the plaintiff who has a burden of proof,
the plaintiff has to prove their case at tie goes to the defendant,
if you will.
The plaintiff with a burden of proof is supposed to get a pic of forum.
By that it means if you've got to prove your case,
you should be allowed to choose in which court you want to do it.
Realistically and America,
all of our courts are supposed to be fair,
but practically we recognize that some are more plaintiff friendly and some are
more defense friendly.
And so,
uh,
the plaintiff's naturally try to find those courts that are plaintiff friendly.
The defendants want defense friendly courts.
We tried the first case in Texas.
Texas has a reputation for being plaintiff friendly.
Realistically,
I think at this point in time it's probably not.
Our judge was appointed to the bench by George Bush when he was governor of
Texas.
George Bush.
President Bush is certainly a no friend to trial lawyers.
Um,
uh,
we have an appellate court system in Texas that is entirely Republican.
Uh,
there will not be a democratic judge that we'll ever see.
The,
the Vioxx case.
We have a,
we tried in Texas are the one's pending right now to my knowledge.
Um,
in New Jersey you've got a different scenario.
You've got a court system that's very friendly,
uh,
ideologically,
at least with big Pharma.
Pharma has a home in New Jersey,
has great tort in New Jersey.
And until we got the punitive damage finding against Merck had never been held
responsible for punitive damages in New Jersey.
Under the current state of the law.
If you Google a judicial Hellhole,
uh,
you will find a map showing the most plaintive friendly jurisdictions in the
country and the huge ideological battle and political battle,
which is in progress about federalizing and capping a tort law awards,
uh,
is out there.
Just,
just go tort reform or judicial hell holes and you'll get the flavor of it.
So a New Jersey is somewhere that I think Merck would like.
I'm going to skip a good bed here.
Sorry.
This is fairly,
the Harvard business school slide that I put a was not the first slide I showed,
but it certainly was a,
in my opening statement.
I wanted the jury to understand that when it,
but before Ray Gilmartin came on board,
Merck,
which was 1994,
Merck was run basically by a CEO named Doctor Vagi Vagelos and doctor Vagelos,
who's a world renowned doctor,
phenomenal doctor.
When Ray Gilmartin came on board,
Merck didn't hire a world renowned doctor to run the company.
Merck didn't hire world renowned chemist or even a nationally known chemist.
I heck,
I didn't take gun a local chemist.
They didn't hire a pharmacist.
Someone who had experience with pills and medicines,
uh,
on,
on even a local level,
much less than national level.
What Merck did is they took a different direction.
They change directions from the Vagelos days,
Dr [inaudible] days and they hired an MBA,
which I have a lot of respect for Mbas,
but I think we need to put into context what it was speaking to it within the
Merck culture.
It was saying no longer is science running our company.
We're now going to run this company along economic terms is a business and ray
go,
Martin came in as a Harvard trained in Ba who had really no science background
whatsoever and it was an,
I put the Harvard business school slide up to to put a visual image to go with
the intellectual concept that Merck was choosing to be a business first company.
It's not a patient.
When we tried the Erin's case,
I was stunned at the opening that Merck gave understand Bob Burns died from
what's called sudden cardiac death.
Sudden Cardiac death means you are dead by the time you're in the hospital.
And the cause is,
is not something they can easily trace,
but it's clearly a heart problem.
A,
the sudden cardiac death was attributed to an Arrhythmia,
which is a ventricular fibrillation for him is his heart was quivering.
And the question ultimately becomes what caused that heart quivering Arrhythmia.
Uh,
most typically,
according to the Merck manual,
it's caused by a heart attack.
Uh,
but it can be caused by an electrocution.
It can be caused by a inhaling a lot of salt water in a drowning and it can be
caused by,
uh,
being exposed to too hyperthermia.
Um,
clearly none of those is what had happened to Bob Burns.
Bob Burns had had a heart attack.
I was stunned in opening when the Merck lawyer stood up and told the jury
disingenuously I believe that if the jury looked at the coroner's report,
they would see that the coroner said,
uh,
Bob Barnes had not had a heart attack.
Bob Burns had died from Arrhythmia secondary to atherosclerosis.
Well,
those are both caused by a heart attack.
Uh,
[inaudible],
you know,
someone may have died from a loss of blood.
Okay.
But if someone was shot and it was the gunshot that caused the bleeding and the
loss of blood,
it's disingenuous to stand up and tell the jury,
oh,
they didn't die from the bullet.
They died from loss of blood.
And so I was shocked by that because I thought it was a misrepresentation and I
think mark did it thinking they could get away with it because no one had ever
been able to find the coroner and ask her what she meant.
And so I don't have any testimony to the contrary.
We just have a report.
So I went back to my office and I said,
I want the coroner.
And they said,
we can't find the corner.
I said,
we can find anybody except bin.
Ladin find the corner.
We hired a couple of pis.
We found the coroner doing pathology work in the United Arab Emirates Abu Dhabi.
I shot her an email asking her if she would mind if I spoke with her.
She emailed back and said she'd be glad to speak with me.
I called her on the phone and I said,
here is what was said about this case and opening,
here's what your autopsy said.
Tell me about it.
She said,
well he died,
you know,
on during an autopsy I have to put the physical cause a physical,
cause it was a sudden cardiac death with an Arrhythmia,
secondary death row sclerosis as well.
How does that kill you?
And she said,
easy,
you have a heart attack.
I said,
really?
She said,
of course,
that's the only thing that causes atherosclerosis,
causes heart attack.
The heart attack causes an arrhythmia.
She said,
unless he was electrocuted.
And she said,
was he electrocuted?
And I said No.
She said,
okay.
I said,
would you come over and explain that to the jury?
She said,
I'd be glad to.
So she came over while merch threw a fit because Merck says we never would have
told the jury what we did,
if we'd known Lanier was going to be allowed to tell the truth about it.
So,
uh,
uh
Oh,
that's what,
that film is almost an hour long.
We had it made for the Mbas a couple of years ago.
Mary Pat,
uh,
you're not the coroner.
Uh,
but if I asked you,
is there a,
is there another set of relationships that involve Merck that were,
uh,
behind the scenes and all this and,
and what you know about him?
Help me out.
Sure.
Um,
well,
in addition to all the plaintiffs who brought cases against Merck,
mark also had taken out insurance policies for product liability and liability
exposure insurance,
and they took them from a bunch of companies like Munich reinsurance.
And at the same time that all of these cases were going on,
mark was trying to collect on those policies.
Um,
basically they wanted money because they had to pull Vioxx and all the exposure.
they were losing a lot of money in profits that way.
But,
um,
these insurance companies were saying,
well,
you are exercising a breach of warranty because when you took out these
policies,
you basically told us that,
you know,
this sort of a thing wouldn't happen,
but we're saying that you knew something like this would happen.
Okay.
And,
uh,
did the company,
you're close relative represented end up paying or not?
Um,
they paid some of the damages but not all.
So I'm sort of a negotiated settlement.
Yeah.
Let's see.
I'm not getting my images back and we'll do without them.
Uh,
let me finish this.
the uh,
ultimate outcome was a negotiated settlement,
uh,
amounting not to 12 and a half billion dollars as a mark linear thought or
claimed to think,
uh,
but,
4.8 5 billion.
And what happens is the court system creates a class action suit and then
subtle.
So the class action suit in a way which creates a scoring system for the
plaintiffs,
the tens of thousands of plaintiffs.
And you,
uh,
the score you get depends on how long you've used the drug,
and how severely you suffered and how the causal connection between what
happened to you and the drug is.
For example,
if you talk Vioxx for a short period of time,
but we're a 280 pound diabetic with a major smoking problem and accorded day
Bourbon problem.
Uh,
the odds were that you weren't going to get a lot of money out of the
settlement.
So it's a mechanical system,
and I personally believe that when used within reasonable limits,
common law is a way of protecting relatively small people against large
companies.
And the adjudication of that boundary,
which is now in progress,
is very important.
The killer for large companies is the tr the transaction costs of saddling a so
many cases,
uh,
can themselves be prohibitive.
Okay.
Exam on Wednesday and,
uh,
back to work on Monday.